la séance est ouverte le compte rendu
analytique de la précédente séance a été
distribuée pas d'observation le
procès-verbal est adopté sous les
réserves d'usage
mes chers collègues j'ai le regret de
vous faire part du décès de notre ancien
collègue yann Gaillard qui fut sénateur
de l'aube de 1994 à 2014
l'ordre du jour appelle le débat sur
l'enseignement professionnel à la
demande du groupe les républicains la
parole est tout d'abord à l'orateur du
groupe qui a demandé ce débat monsieur
Max Brisson pour le groupe les
républicains pour 8 minutes
oui
[Applaudissements]
ce président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues avec un élève sur trois
du second cycle du secondaire soit 650
mille élèves inscrits après la troisième
pour être formé du CAP au baccalauréat
non seulement professionnel est une voie
importante de notre système éducatif
pourtant la filière a perdu 100000
élèves en même temps et ses résultats
pour l'obtention d'un emploi sont
décevant deux ans après avoir obtenu
leur diplôme seul 41% des titulaires
d'un CAP 50% des bacheliers
professionnels trouvent un emploi pour
beaucoup de jeunes instruments
professionnels les vécu comme une voix
de relégation une sanction à leur
difficulté scolaire une filière de
l'échec alors qu'elles sont valorisées
dans d'autres pays comme l'Allemagne la
Suisse ou des Pays-Bas les formations
professionnelles souffrent en France
d'une image dégradée qui ne fait rêver
ni les jeunes ni leurs parents il n'est
pas étonnant à ces conditions que
l'affectation en filière professionnelle
reproduise les inégalités ex
un élève issu de milieu défavorisé à 93%
de probabilité d'être orienté vers un
lycée professionnel et plus de la moitié
des lycéens de cette filière vient de
quartier défavorisés selon une étude
réalisée par Sciences Po un tiers des
élèves de l'enseignement professionnel
sont boursiers soit le double des élèves
de l'enseignement général les enfants de
cadre de représentent que 7% des
effectifs de la voie professionnelle
l'éducation nationale a une
responsabilité en la matière en ne
valorisant que par trop les disciplines
générales avec des enseignants de
connaissant pas ou peu les filières
professionnelles ni même souvent les
métiers vers lequel est le mène il est
également incontestable que trop de
jeunes sont formés à des métiers qui ne
débouchent pas sur un emploi à la sortie
du bac ainsi 60% des lycéens
professionnels sont scolarisés dans des
filières tertiaires du bac professionnel
alors que celle-ci recrute au niveau bac
+
plus largement les effectifs sont
surtout concentrés en Commerce et Vente
et sanitaires et sociales hormis à part
l'aide à domicile de l'hôtellerie
restauration les pénuries de compétences
se focalisent aujourd'hui dans
l'industrie or c'est dans ce secteur que
les lycées professionnels réussissent le
mieux et ce sont souvent ceux où les
synergies avec les entreprises locales
sont les plus fortes ainsi au sable
d'Olonne au lycée Éric Tabarly où
s'exprimer le 13 septembre dernier le
président de la République on trouve en
effet des formations insérantes telles
que la chaudronnerie ou la maintenance
nautique preuve que le système abrite
aussi de réels pépites et c'est
justement à la suite des déclarations du
président de la République que le groupe
les républicains a demandé le présent
débat l'annonce d'une réforme d'ampleur
au sable de l'homme par le chef de
l'État interpelle un effet sur le fond
et la forme la réforme de 2019
n'entendait-elle pas déjà favoriser les
synergies entre la voie scolaire et le
monde de l'apprentissage pour que les
deux systèmes jouent la carte de la
complémentarité selon les termes du
ministre d'alors ne s'agissait-il pas de
transformer les établissements
professionnels en Harvard professionnel
cette ambition semble avoir tourné court
pourtant sans analyse de la réforme de
2019 les annonces faites par le
président de République fixent dès à
présent un cadre précis doublement des
heures de stage révision de la carte des
formations réorientation des enseignants
recrutement de personnels issus du monde
professionnel après avoir annoncé ces
mesures très précises le président
Emmanuel Macron a recours à une série de
débats sur le modèle du Conseil national
de la refondation on peut s'interroger
sur la méthode
quatre groupes de travail doivent un
effet se réunir jusqu'aux vacances de
Noël avant des conclusions fin février
malgré la profusion de rapports et
d'études déjà disponible les groupes
devront trouver des solutions aux
questions fixées par vous madame la
ministre comment réduire le nombre de
décrocheurs comment mieux préparer les
poursuites de d'études supérieures
comment améliorer le tout accès à
l'emploi comment donner des marges de
manoeuvre aux établissements tout en
conservant le caractère national des
diplômes les groupes composés de
représentants des syndicats des régions
des parents d'élèves des établissements
des entreprises ou encore des
collectivités sont pilotés par recteur
accompagnés d'un inspecteur général
après les inquiétudes provoquées par les
réformes annoncées par le chef de l'État
aux Sables-d'Olonne on comprend la
volonté du gouvernement de manifestement
rassurés cependant les principaux
syndicats d'enseignants qui dénoncent un
passage en force ont refusé de
participer à ces groupes de travail une
mobilisation a eu lieu le 18 octobre
dernier il doit être renouvelé cette
semaine elle traduit les difficultés de
mise en oeuvre des pistes proposées par
le chef de l'État la double tutelle
exercée dorénavant sur la réforme des
lycées professionnels par les ministères
du Travail et de l'éducation nationale
est également l'objet d'inquiétude
certains y voit le renforcement
bénéfique du lien entre le lycée
professionnel et le marché du travail
donc il voit le signe d'une atteinte à
la spécificité de leur statut et
craignent que l'augmentation voire le
doublement de la durée des stages Brive
de centaines d'heures d'enseignement les
jeunes qui en ont le plus besoin sans
trancher le débat en observant
simplement les évolutions des différents
pays on ne peut constater qu'il n'y a
pas de formation professionnelle de
qualité qui ne repose sur un solide
socle commun de culture et de
compétences générales il ne s'agit pas
par ailleurs d'une condition pour
l'accès à des études supérieures après
le bac pro
quel que soit le point de vue adopté et
sans anticiper le débat que nous aurons
tout à l'heure le sujet sensible de la
durée des stages soulève de nombreuses
questions c'est à travers elle que l'on
peut aborder le sujet sans préjugé ni
tabou comment trouver à ces entreprises
pour accueillir les élèves alors que
c'est déjà une difficulté faut-il
proposer des incitations aux entreprises
pour ouvrir un vivier d'offres les
lycéens percevront-ils d'une
rémunération versée par l'État comme
cela a déjà été évoqué le rapprochement
avec le monde professionnel
impliquera-t-il pour les lycées de
recruter davantage de professeurs
associés
issus des entreprises se rapprochement
passera-t-il par une participation
accrue à la gouvernance des conseils
d'administration des lycées n'est-il pas
indispensable de mieux adapter la carte
des formations aux réalités économiques
afin d'améliorer l'insertion
professionnelle des diplômés et dans ce
cas comment organiser la reconversion
des enseignants pour faire et ici au
Sénat je dirais surtout d'abord comment
mieux associer les collectivités qui
sont les mieux à même de faire le lien
entre les besoins des entreprises et
l'offre de formation on le voit les
questions sont nombreuses mais tous les
efforts seront verts si nous ne
parvenons pas à rétablir l'image d'un
enseignement professionnel adapté aux
élèves et leurs difficultés aussi bien
qu'au besoins de secteurs d'économie
d'avenir le groupe est républicains
souhaitent que le présent débat
contribue à éclairer la voie à suivre
aussi bien par ces questionnements que
par ses propositions et que le Parlement
soit associé à cette rénovation
indispensable c'est le signe peut bien
entendu se construire sans discussion
avec les branches et les partenaires
sociaux n'est pas davantage en évitant
la représentation nationale alors madame
la ministre vous engagez-vous à revenir
devant le Parlement pour en débattre je
vous remercie
merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant à madame Carole
Grandjean ministre délégué chargé de
l'enseignement et de la formation
professionnelle elle aussi pour une
durée de 8 minutes
vous avez la parole madame la ministre
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de la Commission monsieur
Lafont monsieur le sénateur Brisson
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
salue le choix du groupe les
républicains d'avoir proposé ce débat
consacré à l'enseignement professionnel
nous partageons toutes et tous au sein
de cette chambre la nécessité de faire
reconnaître l'enseignement en scolaire
professionnel comme une véritable voix
de réussite pour les jeunes leur famille
et leurs employeurs la réforme portée
par la loi liberté de choisir son avenir
professionnel que vous avez voté en 2018
a permis de lever certaines contraintes
administratives au développement de
l'apprentissage
elle aura permis un décollage sans
précédent en se combinant aux primes
exceptionnels mis en place pendant la
crise au moment où je vous parle nous
atteignons cette année encore un nombre
de contrats historiques les remontées
des organismes de formation nous
indiquent que nous allons dépasser le
cap des 735 milles contrats signés en
2022 probablement plus de 800000 ce qui
correspond à 2 à 3 fois le nombre
d'apprentis que comptait notre pays en
l'essor concibles considérable de
l'apprentissage a contribuer à faire
diminuer le taux de chômage des jeunes
de manière durable en le situeront à
15,9%. l'ambition commune que nous
portons avec le monsieur ministre Papen
Diagne ministre de l'éducation nationale
et de la jeunesse est identique faire de
la voie professionnelle une voix de
choix et d'excellence le changement
d'image est possible nous l'avons
observé concernant l'apprentissage il
est possible et nécessaire concernant le
lycée professionnel
nous devons reconnaître qu'aujourd'hui
le lycée professionnel ne joue pas
suffisamment son rôle d'insertion
professionnelle de l'élève la situation
actuelle est source de frustration aussi
bien pour les jeunes et leurs familles
que pour les enseignants eux-mêmes ce
sentiment de déclassement d'être méprisé
par un système qui semble punir des
enfants en difficulté nourrit le
ressentiment et l'échec des changements
en matière de transformation de la voie
professionnelle ont déjà été déployés
lors du précédent quinquennat dans un
contexte difficile de crise sanitaire
cette première transformation fournit un
socle sur lequel nous devons continuer
de bâtir pour aller plus loin dans le
cadre d'un investissement structurel et
résolument tourné vers la réussite des
élèves
c'est notre responsabilité à tous
rétablir l'ascenseur social pour ces
jeunes et permettre de rendre tangibles
l'égalité des chances pour les publics
les plus fragiles les lycées
professionnels on le sait trop peu
accueille un tiers des jeunes icéants en
France qui sont souvent des enfants qui
cumulent des vulnérabilités scolaires et
sociales les 627000 lycéens
professionnels sont en effet
majoritairement
issus de milieux défavorisés et se
retrouvent en situation d'échec pour
pendant ou à l'issue de leur scolarité
voici quelques chiffres pour vous en
convaincre
33% d'entre eux sont issus d'une famille
ouvrière et 3% d'une famille de cadres
une forte proportion est issue de
l'immigration où est allophone
5% des élèves sont en situation de
handicap contre 1% dans les lycées
généraux les difficultés de lecture
concernent 28% des élèves en CAP 16% des
élèves issus de baccalauréat
professionnel contre 3,5% des élèves
issus de baccalauréat général la voie
professionnelle comprend deux tiers des
décrocheurs déjà je le rappelle en
difficulté au collège après deux ans et
en dehors de celles et ceux qui
poursuivent leurs études seule la moitié
des élèves sont en emploi en outre
l'organisation pédagogique actuelle ne
prend pas suffisamment en compte les
mutations économiques les réalités des
difficultés des élèves les défis des
territoires et ne s'adaptent pas assez
aux trajectoires et au profil des élèves
les formations sont insuffisamment
tournées vers l'emploi avec des diplômes
qui sont parfois en décalage sans
déboucher sans niveau pertinentes
qualification avec un référentiel
d'activité qui est dépassé la carte des
formations est parfois déconnectée des
enjeux pour le marché du travail avec de
nombreuses formations tertiaires qui ne
sont pas suffisamment insérantes des
investissements dans les plateaux
techniques et les efforts déployés pour
la reconversion des enseignants se
relève se révèle souvent mal connecté
aux réalités économiques la préparation
au monde professionnel n'est pas
suffisante et n'offre pas aux jeunes la
maîtrise nécessaire des codes de
l'entreprise ou des techniques de
recherche d'emploi pour s'insérer
efficacement dans le monde du travail
les formations post-bac sont inadaptées
les BTS préfèrent recruter des
baccalauréats généraux et technologiques
et ne sont pas adaptées aux sortants de
bac pro alors même que dans certains
secteurs c'est le BTS qui est demandé
par les employeurs plutôt que le niveau
baccalauréat professionnel l'offre de
formation préparatoire aux études
supérieures de type la mention
complémentaires ou diplôme de spécialité
professionnelle en une année est
insuffisante
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs nous
nous sommes assignés trois objectifs
clairs pour réussir cette réforme que
nous allons bâtir avec l'ensemble des
acteurs concernés premièrement nous
souhaitons réduire le nombre de
décrocheurs
évitez cette fuite des élèves qui ne
trouvent pas leur place en lycée
professionnel entendons-nous bien
personne n'accuse les lycées
professionnels d'être la cause unique du
décrochage ils en sont souvent le
réceptacle
héritant de difficultés liées à la fois
aux fragilité personnelle des élèves et
au manque de souplesse des parcours de
formation nous devons dès leur trouver
des réponses en leur sein bâtir ensemble
une organisation nouvelle plus souple
qui permettent d'atteindre
collectivement plus de prévention et
d'accompagnement plus de motivation et
plus de sens et d'engagement des jeunes
dans leur parcours voilà ce que nous
visons nous souhaitons également faire
progresser significativement le taux
d'insertion dans l'emploi le taux
baccalauréat professionnel et à fortiori
le cap doivent tenir cette promesse
républicaine d'insertion dans l'emploi
qui est la raison d'être de tous ces
diplômes
c'est à la fois leur ADN en tant que
diplôme professionnel mais c'est aussi
le gage de leur légitimité que je
souhaite renforcer et enfin troisième
objectif je souhaite sécuriser les
poursuites d'études lorsque le projet et
le métier le requiert nos jeunes doivent
pouvoir être mieux préparés mieux
accompagnés aux attendus des études
supérieures notamment celui des BTS
j'aimerais excuser quelques pistes dans
le temps qu'il met accordé pour
effectivement atteindre ces trois
objectifs et réformer le lycée
professionnel pour que chacun de ces
élèves soit en réussite je voudrais dire
que nous souhaitons investir dans les
lycées professionnels comme jamais ce
n'a été fait auparavant c'est la
première fois qu'un président de la
République porte à cette échelle lors
d'une campagne et lors de son projet
présidentiel la voie professionnelle je
crois que c'est véritablement une
volonté d'accompagner l'amélioration de
la formation initiale et continue des
professeurs eux-mêmes mais aussi la
volonté de construire des formations
d'avenir à destination d'élèves qui
soient davantage en phase avec la
préparation des grands défis collectifs
de demain je pense évidemment aux
transitions écologique et numérique mais
aussi à la révolution de la longévité
c'est-à-dire les enjeux du
vieillissement de la population ou
encore le défi de la transition vers une
société plus inclusive et plus solidaire
qui passe vers un meilleur
accompagnement du handicats dans tous
les secteurs et enfin notre politique de
souveraineté économique et de
réindustrialisation du pays la
multiplication des périodes de formation
milieu professionnel les stages combinés
à la gratification des élèves pour ces
périodes doivent permettre de rapprocher
encore davantage le lycée professionnel
du monde de l'entreprise et de conforter
la motivation des élèves et leur
engagement à réussir elle participe à
donner du sens de l'expérience et des
contacts elle vient renforcer ce lien
qui permet effectivement d'être
véritablement dans des périodes de
formation qui se situe en milieu
professionnel renforcer bien sûr les
enseignements généraux et monsieur le
Président de la République la rappeler
car les entreprises en ont autant besoin
celle des compétences
professionnelles des compétences
techniques que de citoyens éclairés dans
leur entreprise voilà je voudrais
simplement conclure en disant que nous
avons lancé quatre groupes de travail
que ces quatre groupes de travail
associés très largement les acteurs du
monde de la formation du monde de
l'éducation du monde économique du monde
des régions bien sûr qui sont des
partenaires des auditions sont également
engagées
dans la suite du débat chaque orateur
dispose de 2 minutes maximum y compris
l'éventuelles réplique le gouvernement
dispose pour répondre d'une durée
équivalente le gouvernement aura la
faculté si le juge nécessaire de
répondre à une réplique pendant une
minute auquel cas l'auteur de la
question disposera alors à son tour du
droit de répondre pendant une minute la
parole est d'abord à Monsieur Pierre
Jean verzelen pour le groupe Les
Indépendants
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues madame la ministre vous
l'aviez dit dans votre propos
l'apprentissage connaît un succès sans
précédent en période de crise pandémique
le nombre d'apprentis a été multiplié
par deux pour atteindre aujourd'hui 740
000 si ces chiffres doivent se confirmer
dans le temps chacun s'accorde à dire
que c'est une action qui est à mettre au
crédit du gouvernement cela nous
rappelle trois choses déjà la première
c'est qu'en matière d'enseignement et de
formation la France ne dépend que
d'elle-même et il y a assez peu de
sujets comme ça ensuite
lorsqu'on met de la volonté politique et
qu'on met les moyens en face les
résultats sont là et enfin
c'est que quand cette attractif pour
l'entreprise et pour le jeûne notamment
je veux dire en matière d'embauche et de
débouchés cela fonctionne la question
qui se pose comment l'enseignement
professionnel peut-il avoir le même élan
certes les problématiques sont
différentes mais nous devons pouvoir
créer des synergies entre les deux l'une
des leçons de l'apprentissage c'est que
les formations se sont adaptées au
bassin d'emploi et aux réalités des
territoires et pour cause les jeunes les
entreprises et aussi les centres de
formation disposent de marge de manœuvre
pour s'organiser nous avons besoin là
ici là encore ici de liberté et de
souplesse l'une des difficultés de
l'enseignement professionnel c'est le
manque de débouchés concret moins d'un
élève sur deux trouve un emploi après 12
mois de 12 mois après sa sortie de
formation
alors ce taux atteint quasiment 70% pour
les apprentis
l'enseignement professionnel même si
cela s'est amélioré et ça a été dit
souffre toujours d'une image qu'il faut
valoriser auprès des jeunes madame la
ministre que comptez-vous faire pour que
l'enseignement professionnel connaissent
le même succès que l'apprentissage
allez-vous donner plus d'autonomie au
chef d'établissement pour leur permettre
de s'adapter au mieux aux besoins et aux
réalités de leur bassin d'emploi merci
merci la parole est à madame la ministre
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur verse Hélène merci pour cette
question qui me permet effectivement de
revenir sur un certain nombre de sujets
au fond déjà je voudrais redire à quel
point effectivement cette réussite de
l'apprentissage qui reste pour nous un
défi que nous souhaitons continuer à
mettre à l'échelle avec un objectif d'un
million d'apprentis reste évidemment une
des réussites pour lutter contre le
chômage des jeunes elle ne doit pas être
la seule et évidemment elle doit
s'accompagner d'autres dispositions et
d'autres leviers le lycée professionnel
concerne des élèves de plus en plus
jeunes et donc pas forcément en âge ou
en maturité pour rentrer dans des
dispositifs d'apprentissage et nous
sommes bien conscients de cela avec
aussi des fragilités que j'évoquais tout
à l'heure et même si je porte la même
ambition pour le Lycée professionnel
parce que je crois en lui dans le lycée
professionnel comme voie de réussite et
d'excellence je ne souhaite pas
finalement mettre en concurrence ces
deux dispositifs qui doivent pouvoir
trouver une une réponse et une
complémentaires pour pour les élèves et
peut-être aussi organiser des passations
des passerelles qui permettent aux
élèves de s'ajuster fonction de leur
maturité lors de leur parcours je
voudrais dire que le contrat
d'apprentissage c'est une option qui est
envisageable déjà pour les lycéens
professionnels aujourd'hui plus de 60000
c'est un professionnel donc un peu moins
de 10% sont en apprentissage en lycée
professionnel c'est plus de 42% en deux
ans et c'est déjà une grande évolution
qui a nécessité un accompagnement
pédagogique de la part des professeurs
de la voix professionnelle mon objectif
est clair c'est celui de transformer
structurellement le lycée professionnel
pour que il y a un accompagnement plus
intensif plus individualisé qui doit
permettre à l'élève d'être en réussite
et ces quatre groupes de travail y
réfléchiront le quatrième groupe de
travail doit réfléchir à la manière dont
on donne des marges de manœuvre des
initiatives aux établissements tout en
conservant le caractère national des
diplômes et j'insiste beaucoup sur le
sujet il s'agit là d'être en
concertation avec les chefs
d'établissement et de leur donner la
capacité à agir à impulser à adapter
aussi les solutions par rapport à leurs
élèves merci Madame oui 7 secondes merci
la parole est à Madame Monique de Marco
pour le groupe écologiste merci monsieur
le président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues au sable de Lognes le 13
septembre le président de la République
a évoqué les grands axes de la réforme
des lycées professionnels rapprochez le
lycée Professionnel des entreprises
fermées des formations et en ouvrir
d'autres le tout en lien avec des
régions bassin d'emploi par bassin
d'emploi autant de bon sens serait
louable s'il ne se bornez pas et
d'écrire l'existant car c'est déjà le
cas le lycée de la mère de Gujan-Mestras
près d'Arcachon ne traite pas de la
montagne et les lycées des métiers du
bois se trouvent déjà dans les régions
forestières comme les Landes
ce qui relève moins du bon sens en
revanche c'est la tendance au
détricotage de l'enseignement
professionnel dans le secondaire dans
laquelle s'inscrit cette réforme moins
d'établissement moins d'élèves moins
d'heures d'enseignement moins de moyens
moins d'enseignants et là cette logique
n'a pas disparu des objectifs des
groupes de travail initiés suite à la
mobilisation exceptionnelle du 18
octobre ou des professeurs lycées
professionnels et des syndicats
aujourd'hui plus de 26% des lycéens
obtiennent un bac professionnel et
pourtant il ne représente que 6% des
étudiants à l'université et 17% en BTS à
côté de leurs connaissances plus
précieuses du monde de l'entreprise les
lycéens de ces filières doivent pouvoir
bénéficier d'un socle d'enseignement
général leur permettant de pouvoir
pétanque tendre si c'est leur ambition à
des cursus dans le supérieur
c'est le cas de la moitié d'entre eux
aujourd'hui je pense notamment aux
écoles supérieures de journalistes et de
communication qui accueillent dans leur
mur des bacs pro artisanat et Métiers
d'Art de l'option communication visuelle
plurimédia tant l'agilité numérique et
technique est devenue capitale
possédilière
pensez-vous sincèrement que la réforme
que vous entendez mettre en place dans
nos bacheliers professionnels une chance
égale pour accéder à des formations
supérieures en adéquation avec nos
aspirations personnelles
merci la parole de Madame la Ministre
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice au fond vous m'interrogez sur
l'enjeu de sécuriser la poursuite
d'études pour les jeunes et c'est
évidemment un des enjeux majeurs de la
réforme que nous souhaitons porter avec
un groupe de travail qui travaille
spécifiquement sur ce sujet pour
accompagner un certain nombre de
propositions répondre
au défi qui se posent aussi sur la
fragilité des élèves leur difficulté
préparer la poursuite d'études lorsque
le projet le requiert ou le métier
effectivement le nécessite il s'agit
pour nous clairement de nous baser sur
un constat que les élèves ont plus de
mal à entrer dans les études supérieures
et que quand ils y entrent ils ont plus
de mal à obtenir le diplôme
d'enseignement supérieur fort de ce
constat nous sommes évidemment
convaincus qu'il faut accompagner la
sécurisation de leur parcours les mettre
là aussi en situation de réussite après
le CAP ou le bac pro parce que ce sont
des diplômes professionnels et qu'ils
doivent
accompagner la sécurisation des parcours
et que c'est donc tout l'objet du groupe
de travail qui va travailler sur ce
sujet sécurisé la poursuite d'études
mais en la préparant également merci
Madame la Ministre la parole est à
Madame durant ton pour le groupe RDPI
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues
l'intelligence de la main vaut
l'intelligence de l'esprit valorisons le
talent de nos enfants et revalorisons la
voie professionnelle elle a longtemps
été considérée comme un choix par défaut
par les élèves et leurs familles en
sortie de classe de troisième
heureusement les mentalités évoluent et
de plus en plus de jeunes l'empreinte un
jeune sur trois selon les chiffres de
votre ministère cette voie s'adresse
principalement à dijones qui sont
motivés pour apprendre un métier et
intégrer rapidement le monde de
l'entreprise pour ces élèves qui ont
besoin de faire et qui ne s'épanouissent
pas dans un enseignement plus théorique
c'est un vrai chemin de réussite dans
l'enseignement professionnel 718
000 contrats d'apprent message ont été
signés en 2021 dont 60000 dans
l'enseignement professionnel c'est une
évolution globale de 40000 contrats de
plus par rapport à 2020 néanmoins un
problème demeure ces jeunes se heurtent
souvent à des difficultés pour trouver
leur stage leur alternance ou leur
apprentissage dans une entreprise qui
leur fera confiance comment faire pour
renforcer ce lien de proximité entre le
milieu éducatif et l'entreprise
peut-être en organisant plus de forums
pour les mettre en relation en
s'appuyant davantage sur les chambres
consulaires des incitations aux
entreprises impliquer les collectivités
juste après l'obtention du CAP ou du bac
pro c'est sorti rapide ne sont pas
toujours coronées de succès puisque
seulement 32% des titulaires du CAP et
45% des titulaires du bras du bac pro
trouve un emploi dans les 12 mois qui
suivent madame la ministre il y a à
l'évidence des marges de progrès pour
améliorer la recherche d'emploi de ces
jeunes qui souhaitent rentrer rapidement
dans la vie active
quelles sont les pistes que vous
envisagez pour leur permettre de trouver
plus facilement un emploi et quels sont
les leviers qui pourraient inciter les
entreprises à les recruter plus
rapidement alors qu'elles recherchent
des salariés je vous remercie merci
madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice au fond vous m'interrogez sur
la manière d'améliorer l'insertion dans
l'emploi des élèves en voie
professionnelle nous savons les diplômes
professionnels obtiennent des résultats
encore trop insuffisants pour
l'insertion des jeunes alors qu'il
existe de nombreux métiers en tension
dans notre pays et des nombres métiers
d'avenir à préparer je tiens à dire que
nous avons aussi des résultats très
inégaux selon les lycées professionnels
avec des résultats et des taux
d'insertion très inégaux et donc
évidemment il s'agit là de moyenne je
voudrais dire que j'ai installé un
groupe de travail dans la mission est
spécifiquement liée au renforcement de
l'insertion professionnelle après le
diplôme pour renforcer l'employabilité
de chacun des diplômes concernés de les
adapter au public et de les inscrire
dans des parcours de réussite au fond ce
groupe de travail va pouvoir réfléchir
sur les enjeux de carte de formation
finalement les territoires doivent
pouvoir proposer aussi une offre qui
soit à la fois large pour offrir pour
offrir de vraies perspectives en lien
avec les besoins des entreprises et du
bassin d'emploi mais aussi offrir un
choix de diplôme pour un élève qui
pourrait être utilement éclairé à
travers l'orientation en amont et un
accompagnement régulier au cours de la
formation et puis préparer un diplôme
suppose aussi personnalisation qui
accompagne aussi bien les enjeux
techniques que les compétences
psychosociales rapprochent aussi bien
les enjeux de formation dans
l'établissement que celles en entreprise
et au fond tout vient se souvient
concorder dans l'accompagnement des
jeunes vous l'aurez compris aucune piste
n'étaitquée c'est pour nous en tout cas
une multitude de questions qui se posent
autour de d'un enjeu qui nous avons
encore une fois des jeunes plus jeunes
et donc au fond
quelles proposition pourrait-on
envisager une solution d'accompagnement
après le diplôme une année ou quelques
mois de scolarité complémentaires avant
le monde du travail ou aperçu d'études
pourquoi pas des modalités permettant
aux jeunes de faire davantage de stages
en entreprise au fond toutes les options
sont ouvertes à ce stade l'idée c'est
véritablement d'associer le monde
d'économiques et évidemment le monde
éducatif pour que nous travaillons tous
ensemble à se rapprochement et elle
cette réussite merci la parole est
maintenant madame Marie-Pierre Monnier
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues je me
réjouis que nous ayons ce temps de débat
sur l'enseignement professionnel au sein
de notre hémicycle et je remercie le
groupe les républicains pour cette
initiative je souhaitais pour ma part
vous interroger sur la volonté du
Président de la République d'adapter
l'offre de formation des lycées
professionnels aux besoins des bassins
d'emploi locaux s'il s'engage dans cette
voie le lycée professionnel verrouillera
le destin des élèves qui en fréquente
les bancs puisque leur appartenance
géographique à cet instant T déterminera
leur carrière professionnelle alors
qu'il faudrait justement veiller à ne
fermer aucune porte à ses élèves y
compris dans l'accès à des études
supérieures on réduit leur capacité de
choisir librement leur avenir d'autant
plus que la réforme prévoit également la
diminution des heures d'enseignement
fondamentaux cette vision de court terme
ne prend par ailleurs pas en compte la
diversité des territoires alors quid de
ceux où les bassins économiques sont
sinistré et l'accès à l'emploi déjà
compliqué elle fait également pesée sur
les établissements et professeurs dans
la formation ne serait plus jugée
adaptée la lourde charge de la
reconversion pour répondre à ses
nouveaux besoins peut-être éphémère par
ailleurs enfin elle interroge sur la
philosophie même de notre école le seul
rôle de notre lycée professionnel
serait-il de fournir une main d'oeuvre
prête à l'emploi pour les entreprises
locales les alertes dont je vous fais
part sont partagés par les parents
d'élèves et les par les syndicats
attachés comme devrions toutes et tous
l'être à la dimension nationale du bac
professionnel et à la garantie de
l'égalité entre les élèves en
tiendrez-vous compte dans le cadre des
groupes de travail que vous menez pour
élaborer cette réforme
merci la parole est à madame la ministre
si monsieur le Président Madame
sénatrice vous m'interrogez sur
l'adéquation entre les besoins du marché
et les offres de formation en voie
professionnelle je voudrais déjà
m'arrêter un instant sur les grandes
disparités qui existent déjà aujourd'hui
au fond le taux d'insertion aussi entre
10% et 80%. donc cette réalité elle doit
nous interroger elle doit évidemment
nous amener à réfléchir sur des enjeux
majeurs comme l'adéquation entre la
carte des formations et une meilleure
insertion comme effectivement
l'accompagnement en termes d'insertion
dans l'emploi des jeunes qui sont pas
toujours en acquisition des codes de
l'entreprise elle doit aussi nous
interroger sur l'accompagnement sur les
savoirs fondamentaux je crois l'avoir
dit redit et redit tout comme le
président de la République l'a dit est
redit nous sommes attachés au savoir
fondamentaux et nous maintiendrons une
qualité des anciens allemands fans
fondamentaux parce que nous sommes
convaincus que accompagner de futurs
professionnels c'est aussi accompagner
des citoyens éclairés et que leur
citoyenneté elle est aussi déterminante
dans leur vie de demain dans leur
parcours individuel comme dans leur
parcours professionnel je voudrais dire
que nous allons travailler aussi sur la
découverte des métiers car cette
question de l'orientation subit est un
vrai sujet qui doit évidemment là aussi
être travaillé sur lequel les groupes de
travail travailleront dans le cadre
notamment du groupe de travail sur le
décrochage cette question n'a synergie
entre les quarts de formation et les
besoins économiques elle ne se travaille
pas je vous rassure même la sénatrice
sur du court terme elle se travaille
parce qu'il y a des enjeux de projection
dans l'emploi elle se travaille parce
qu'effectivement on voit qu'il y a des
mutations économiques à venir elle ne
d'ailleurs elle ne se travaille pas en
quelques semaines ou en quelques mois
elle se travaille en formant les
enseignants en préparant les plateaux
techniques en préparant effectivement le
lien avec les entreprises et donc tout
cela se passe dans la durée et
évidemment pour des projets de
d'appréhension des mutations économiques
et des métiers d'avenir si le lycée
professionnel ne s'empare pas de défi
c'est le lycée professionnel qui laisse
la place à d'autres acteurs et
évidemment je crois que vous comme moi
nous sommes convaincus que les lycées
professionnels a toute sa place à
prendre dans ses dispositifs de
formation pour nos jeunes merci Madame
la Ministre 13 secondes madame Monier
vous dites que vous êtes attaché au
savoir fondamentaux mais en réduisant
les heures d'enseignement général vous
les mettez à mal et ensuite il ne faut
pas confondre je trouve que dans les
débats on mélange un petit peu
apprentissage qui n'est pas l'un des me
voir que le lycée professionnel
la parole est maintenant madame Céline
brûlin pour le groupe CRCE merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues des réformes ont
déjà fait perdre beaucoup d'heures de
cours au lycéen de l'enseignement
professionnel et particulièrement dans
les disciplines générales résultat les
élèves de CAP n'ont par exemple plus
qu'une heure trente de français
hebdomadaire vous envisagez d'augmenter
les périodes de stage en milieu
professionnel ce qui se traduirait
inévitablement par une nouvelle
réduction des formations théoriques
madame la ministre mesurez-vous les
conséquences d'un tel choix alors même
que les élèves de l'enseignement
professionnel ont besoin des
enseignements généraux car ils en sont
souvent les plus éloignés comment ce qui
le souhaitent pourrait-il poursuivre des
études supérieures à l'issue d'un tel
cursus et comment d'ailleurs envisager
sérieusement une augmentation
significative des périodes en entreprise
quand on sait la difficulté à trouver
des terrains de stage vous dites
également vouloir augmenter la
rémunération des stages pour la lignée
sur celle des apprentis les apprentis à
la différence des stagiaires qui
perçoivent une gratification et sous son
statut son statut scolaire sont des
salariés de l'entreprise qui les
embauchent ils perçoivent à ce titre un
salaire quel sera le statut des lycéens
qui les rémunérera combien et comment
les élèves des lycées professionnels qui
représentent un tiers des lycéens de
notre pays méritent d'être traités à
égal dignité de ceux de la voie générale
enfin depuis juin dernier un décret
permet aux enseignants des lycées
professionnels d'enseigner en lycée
général et technologique et en collège
avec l'avantage que ceci dispense de
matière différentes cette réforme
serait-elle une manière inavouée de
faire face à la crise de recrutement que
nous connaissons dans l'éducation
nationale en raison de la faiblesse des
salaires et du manque de reconnaissance
des enseignants
merci la parole est à madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice écoutez permettez-moi de le
réaffirmer il n'y a pas de diminution
des heures dans saignement en général
des élèves de CAP et de bac
professionnel au contraire nous
souhaitons faire mieux dans
l'enseignement généraux permettez-moi de
vous rappeler ce que je disais tout à
l'heure en préambule c'est tôt de
difficultés en lecture d'ores et déjà
aujourd'hui et avant même la réforme de
la TVP nous avons 28% d'élèves issus de
cap qui ont des difficultés en lecture
16% des élèves
issus de baccalauréat professionnel
cette ce constat nous appelle à l'action
et à l'ajustement effectivement des
modalités pédagogiques pour les
accompagner pour faire non pas moins
pour faire mieux de d'enseignements je
le redis parce que je ne sais plus
comment vous le dire pour que vous ne
cessiez pour vous cessiez de déformer
mes propos encore une fois nous avons
effectivement le constat d'une maîtrise
nettement plus faible des avoir
fondamentaux que les élèves de la voie
générale et technologique et c'est donc
notre responsabilité que de pouvoir
mettre les moyens qu'il faudra pour
parvenir à la réduction de ces écarts
encore une fois le lien est que
l'entreprise nous paraît extrêmement
importante et donc au travers de la
découverte des métiers que nous allons
aussi créer cette capacité à avoir une
orientation choisie et c'est un de nos
défis mais aussi l'accès à l'information
et vous l'avez cité madame la sénatrice
nous avons fait beaucoup sous le
précédent mandat pour organiser les
conditions de l'interaction entre les
familles les élèves et les entreprises
au travers notamment d'un jeune une
solution vous me permettez également de
rappeler le dispositif insert jeune qui
permet de voir toute la lisibilité sur
les taux d'insertion dans chaque diplôme
ainsi que le dispositif à fenêtre qui
est un outil pour nous d'affectation et
qui nous permet de travailler en
cohérence avec les cartes de formation
vous voyez là les enjeux sont pour nous
multiples ils dépassent les propos
déformés et nous engage à agir dans
l'intérêt des jeunes et de leur qualité
de savoir fondamentaux merci Madame
brunendus seconde
madame la ministre nous allons continuer
à vous poser des questions et ce qui
serait bien c'est que vous y répondiez
parce que hormis nous dire qu'il y a des
groupes de travail qui ont été mis en
place nous je crois nous n'en savons pas
plus à cette heure qu'avant de rentrer
dans l'hémicycle et donc si nos
collègues des républicains ont voulu
avoir ce débat provoquer ce débat c'est
pas précisant non parce que nous voulons
des réponses
je suis sûr que vous allez être éclairé
par tout le débat la parole est
maintenant madame la Présidente Annick
billon
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues je souhaite
tout d'abord bien entendu m'associer aux
remerciements pour le groupe les
républicains qui a demandé ce débat et
particulièrement notre collègue Max
Brisson lors de sa visite au lycée
Eric Tabarly avec vous Madame la
Ministre courant septembre en Vendée au
sable de l'olonne le président Emmanuel
Macron a reconnu qu'il fallait informer
les collégiens plutôt et mieux sur les
formations professionnelles les
établissements Vendéens avec lesquels
j'ai pu échanger partage le même constat
faute d'informations les débouchés
multiples des lycées professionnels ne
sont absolument pas valorisés et ce
alors même que les choix en termes
d'études supérieures et de passerelles
ne manquent pas allant du certificat de
spécialisation à l'école d'ingénieur en
passant par le BTS le but et la licence
comment prenez encourager l'excellence
des filières professionnelles si nos
jeunes n'ont pas de visibilité sur le
post-bac pro et qui n'ont notamment pas
conscience de la possibilité de
poursuivre des études au-delà du lycée
madame la ministre quand on est vous
faire pour offrir aux élèves et aux
familles mais également au professeur et
aux établissements du secondaire l'accès
à une formation complète et qualitative
pour une orientation éclairée
orientation rimant avec affectation j'en
arrive au second point de mon
intervention actuellement le service en
ligne affectation accessible aux élèves
de 3e repose uniquement sur un arbitrage
basé sur les résultats académiques
obtenus par les élèves au cours de leur
scolarité de la décision d'orientation
prise au conseil de classe de fin de
troisième et du nombre de places
disponibles l'intérêt et l'appétence des
élèves pour le secteur de la filière à
laquelle il candidate ne sont pas prises
en compte aussi madame la ministre que
comptez-vous mettre en place pour
intégrer le projet professionnel de
chaque élève au système d'affectation je
vous remercie
merci madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président madame la
Présidente billon merci effectivement
nous interpeller sur ce sujet qui est un
sujet majeur clé d'un certain nombre de
travaux de concertation qui sont
actuellement en cours et notamment de
celui lié au décrochage la question du
sens que les jeunes donnent alors
poursuites d'études est évidemment
déterminante c'est pour ça que nous
avons prévu de travailler sur un enjeu
majeur qui est celui de la découverte
des métiers seuls en réalité au fond les
élèves sont aujourd'hui trop orientés
vers la voie professionnelle lorsqu'ils
ont de moins bons résultats que les
autres au collège et une de mes actions
majeures va être de faire évoluer ce
postulat vers une découverte des métiers
au collège de la classe de 5ème parce
que les collégiens sont près de 1 sur 2
à ne connaitre que quelques métiers ceux
qui sont le plus souvent ceux de leur
environnement proche nous devons
travailler sur la découverte de la
variété des métiers et du monde
professionnel
c'est orientations plus choisies seront
un des déterminants pour favoriser la
réussite en voie professionnelle nous
avons également un second enjeu qui
concerne l'accès l'information nous
avons effectivement un ensemble d'outils
qui donnent la capacité aux élèves de
mieux préparer leur avenir en donnant
une meilleure visibilité sur leur
insertion possible et je tiens à saluer
pardon l'outil un jeune une solution où
le dispositif insert jeune qui indique
les capacités d'insertion
professionnelle nous avons par ailleurs
un outil d'affectation en fin de collège
à felnet qui est pensée en cohérence
avec la carte des formations et vous
voyez là un des enjeux pour nous le
troisième enjeu concerne par conséquent
cette carte des formations un travail
sur le choix de chacune des formations
proposées son employabilité à l'issue et
de l'obtention du diplôme doit être
menée en collaboration avec les régions
et à ce titre je tiens à saluer le
premier comité de pilotage national de
la découverte des métiers qui aura lieu
demain et qui sera à Orléans à Orléans
la première rencontre inter-région sur
l'orientation pour aborder ce sujet je
crois vraiment à ce partenariat et ta
région sur ce sujet de l'orientation
merci la parole est au président rock
qui est
pour le groupe RDS oui merci monsieur le
Président
l'enseignement professionnel reste
encore parfois à tort si valoriser
pourtant je rappellerai quand Mars de la
voix professionnelle classique le fameux
campagnolage français est inscrit depuis
2010 au patrimoine culturel immatériel
de l'humanité c'est le titre le
compagnon réseau de transmission des
savoirs et des entités par le métier par
ailleurs pour peu qu'ils soient bien
mieux reconnu socialement comme ce fut
le cas durant la pandémie avec les
promotions dites le premier retrouvé en
ligne tous les métiers ont du sens
l'enseignement professionnel offre
potentiel de parcours nécessaire à la
fois pour répondre l'inspiration de
nombreuses ainsi qu'aux besoins non
satisfaits du marché du travail dans ces
conditions la réforme de ces
professionnels mais davantage
l'entreprise auquel la formation avait
notamment le profil de développement de
l'apprentissage dans tous les secteurs
d'activité et ici professionnel
cependant je m'interrog
a une forte spécialisation de la voix
professionnelle il est en effet observé
que les élèves se concentre pour deux
tiers dans trois spécialités cette
carrière le commerce à la gestion
duration et les soins et services à la
personne à l'autre le monde économique
esprit en son sein une demande
contradictoire les entreprises
souhaitent des profils aux compétences
transversales tandis que les autres
souhaitent davantage des spécialités
proposées aux élèves ainsi madame la
ministre comment résoudre cette équation
entre de nouveaux besoins des
spécialités notamment sous l'effet des
évolutions technologiques et
industrielles et une orientation des
élèves vers le même type de formation
merci madame la ministre
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur là vous êtes là au finalement
au coeur d'un des dispositifs qu'il ne
faut pouvoir effectivement mieux
accompagner celui de rendre la juste
adéquation entre les formations et la
préparation des compétences de nos
jeunes qui doivent qui devront s'adapter
aux métiers et tout au long de leur
carrière professionnelle aux mutations
des métiers qui existeront et puis
évidemment celui des enjeux économiques
qui doivent pouvoir trouver réponse dans
les compétences des personnes qui sont
issues de nos dispositifs de formation
je voudrais dire à quel point le lycée
professionnel c'est déjà emparé de
l'apprentissage et qu'il ne s'agit pas
de la modalité unique le statut scolaire
de toute sa place au lycée professionnel
et nous insistons un véritablement
là-dessus le statut d'apprenti aussi et
on voit bien effectivement son fort et
sort ces dernières années au fond la
variété des besoins que vous évoquez par
les entreprises sont un de nos défis qui
va nous encourager à
la révision de la carte des formations
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure à
travailler avec nos partenaires des
régions pour
identifier les enjeux économiques de
demain le temps que nous accompagnons
s'est transformations et que nous
investissions comme il le faut dans le
la formation des enseignants dans les
partenariats avec les entreprises dans
les plateaux techniques qui vont devoir
effectivement être mis en place nous
devons effectivement préparer les
compétences de demain les compétences
dont nous aurons besoin dans les années
à venir pour que le lycée professionnel
soit au rendez-vous des enjeux d'avenir
de souveraineter industriels et
économique plus largement je voudrais
dire que nous sommes évidemment
conscients que les approches simplistes
n'ont pas leur place dans cette enjeu de
stratégie sur la carte des formations
que si nous devons être beaucoup plus
ambitieux nous devons évidemment
travailler de manière partenariale avec
l'ensemble des acteurs évidemment
régions acteurs économiques pour
dessiner finalement les dangereux les
enjeux des compétences et de notre
souveraineté national en matière de
formation c'est donc là j'ai envie de
dire un des défis qui se pose à nous et
notre coopération doit être maximale
merci la parole est à Monsieur Max
Brisson pour le groupe les républicains
je vais vous donner l'occasion de
répondre aux attentes de précision de
madame brüller Je souhaiterais un effet
que vous reveniez sur la place des
enseignements généraux dans la formation
des jeunes à lycées professionnels
concrètement comment fait-on l'annonce
du doublement de la durée des stages
peut se comprendre pour rapprocher
formation en lycée professionnel et
monde d'entreprise mais comment y
parvenir sans réduire à la portion
congrue la maîtrise des savoirs
fondamentaux pour des élèves qui ne les
maîtrisent qu'un parfaitement il s'agit
pour ces élèves d'un enjeu de réussite
professionnelle comment en effet
intégrer une entreprise sans maîtriser
le socle minimum de connaissances et de
compétences il s'agit d'un enjeu
démocratique pour de futurs citoyens
éclairés Madame le Ministre comment
allez-vous trouver le bon équilibre par
ailleurs réfléchissez-vous à la nature
de ces enseignements généraux ne faut-il
pas renouveler leur contenu et leur
didactique avec les élèves ne désignent
pas comme la suite de de scolarité
marquée par l'échec mais comme un
nouveau point de départ avec cet
objectif ne faut-il pas regarder ce que
font les visser agricoles qui organisent
avec succès un enseignement
socioculturel Milan éducation à
l'entrepôt à l'environnement social et
culturel éducation artistique formation
l'autonomie et à la communication Madame
le Ministre le renouvellement des
enseignements généraux étaient pratiques
est-il alors de du jour de vos
concertations l'expérience des lycée
agricole peut être élargie bref quel est
votre réflexion sur des enseignements
des disciplines non professionnels et
leur place merci madame la ministre
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur vous m'interrogez au fond sur
la répartition au cours de la scolarité
en voie professionnelle entre le temps
d'enseignement général et les périodes
de formation en milieu professionnel au
fond les CAP et les bacs pro sont des
diplômes professionnels à insertion
professionnelle direct pour ceux qui le
souhaitent même si le taux d'accès à
l'emploi après le diplôme doit être
améliorer nous l'avons déjà dit en effet
plus un jeune fréquente l'entreprise
plus il y a de chances de sciences
serrer durablement et c'est de cela que
nous devons prendre en considération
pour les élèves en CAP l'enseignement
professionnel représente 55% du temps de
formation les enseignements généraux 25%
et les stages 20% entre 12 et 16
semaines sur deux ans selon les
spécialités pour les élèves en bac pro
42% du temps est consacré à
l'enseignement professionnel 33% aux
enseignements généraux et 25% au stage
en période de formation en milieu
professionnel soit entre eux 18 et 22
semaines sur les trois années de
formation j'aimerais donc vous rassurer
nous préserverons le temps de savoir
fondamentaux la réforme que nous
conduisons ne s'est pas fixée comme
objectif de réduire le volume
d'enseignement au lycée professionnel
qu'il soit général ou à caractère
professionnel s'il faut davantage de
temps au lycéeen en voie professionnelle
pour se faire mieux et plus
d'entreprises il faut aussi faire plus
et mieux d'enseignements tous tes
options se rendent donc étudiées pour
faire se compromis avec notamment
possiblement des tons complémentaires
pour nos élèves qui auront le plus
besoin je voudrais dire à quel point je
crois qu'il est important de sortir du
dogme de l'opposition des modèles nous
sommes par exemple effectivement très
intéressés par le modèle de l'issette du
lycée agricole qui n'a pas la même
échelle et ne peut hermait pas forcément
les mêmes possibles à l'échelle du lycée
professionnel mais c'est un modèle qui
est effectivement fonctionne et que nous
avons largement écouté et associés au
groupe de travail qui sont actuellement
en cours de réflexion et qui doivent
pouvoir apporter des propositions
effectivement leur modèle est aussi un
modèle inspirant
merci 28 secondes monsieur Brisson
merci monsieur le Président je crois que
vous cherchez la cotation du cercle
c'est à dire que vous voulez à la fois
préserver le temps de l'enseignement
général et augmenter le stage en
entreprise vous êtes confronté un
véritable problème lié aux annonces du
président de la République qui est
peut-être été imprudent quand il a fait
ce type d'annonce et on renvoie bien une
forme de méthode dont je parlais tout à
l'heure et je regrette que vous n'ayez
pas répondu non plus au contenu de ses
enseignements généraux qui ont besoin
d'être rénovés et voilà un beau sujet
pour vos groupes de concertation merci
la parole est maintenant monsieur Yann
chanterelle pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain merci monsieur
le président madame la ministre nous
partageons avec vous le constat qu'une
réforme de la voix professionnelle est
indispensable il n'est plus tolérable
que ces établissements qui accueillent
près d'un tiers des lycéens et des
lycéens de notre pays soient perçus
comme une voie de garage où la
destination des élèves en échec scolaire
l'urgence est à la revalorisation de ces
formations qu'elle soit perçue comme un
lieu de réussite de découvertes de
passion ou d'innovation or depuis les
annonces du président de la République
on ne nous parle que de courbes du
chômage de taux d'emploibilité de taux
d'insertion et d'un allongement ça a été
largement évoqué par mes collègues de 50
% des périodes de stage que personne ne
demande vous faites comme si c'était la
formation elle-même voire les
enseignants qui étaient en cause et que
la convergence avec l'apprentissage
était la seule issue or pour beaucoup
les élèves qui arrivent en filière
professionnelle ont vécu une orientation
subie ils arrivent brisés par le système
scolaire et c'est au contact justement
de leurs enseignants qu'ils reprennent
confiance avec des parcours exemplaires
d'étudiants qui deviennent expérimentés
conseillère bancaires d'autres ouvrent
leur propre boutique ou poursuivent des
études en art ou en audiovisuel c'est
moins le cas en stage où les horaires
excessifs le travail de nuit
l'exposition produit toxique voir le
harcèlement sont trop souvent le
quotidien de stagiaires perçu comme une
main d'oeuvre gratuite c'est pourquoi
c'est l'attractivité de la voie
professionnelle à travers notamment
l'enseignement général qu'il faut
renforcer c'est pourquoi je vous demande
comme mes autres collègues que de
revenir sur vos propositions
d'allongement de la durée des stages et
plutôt que de que de les baisser
d'augmenter les heures d'enseignement
généraux qui permettent à ces enfants de
s'émanciper de choisir leur destin et
ainsi ouvrir également de nouvelles
filières dans les métiers d'avenir ceux
de numérique des médias ou du
développement durable
merci la parole est à la ministre merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur au fond je crois avoir déjà
répondu à un certain nombre de points
que vous avez cités effectivement les
difficultés sont bien souvent préalables
au lycée professionnel et sur lesquels
pour autant les réponses n'ont pas
toujours été apportées c'est la donne
tout autre défi et notre volonté la
découverte des métiers sera une des
solutions pour effectivement accompagner
mieux l'orientation choisie et il n'est
en aucun cas dans notre esprit de ne pas
se dire que effectivement les
enseignants se lèvent le matin pour
faire réussir leurs élèves et que ce ne
sont pas des enseignants formidables
c'est au système d'évoluer ce n'est pas
aux élèves ce n'est pas leur famille ce
n'est pas aux enseignants c'est au
système d'évoluer pour favoriser
l'attractivité de la filière du lycée
pro et pour vous tout vous dire moi je
pense que l'attractivité du lycée
professionnel elle viendra quand le taux
d'insertion sera effectivement comme
dans certains diplômes aujourd'hui à
près de 80 quand vous voyez
effectivement que vous êtes sur des sous
dans un taux d'insertion qui sont après
de 10% oui je crois effectivement que
l'attractivité de ces filières pose
véritablement question c'est donc tout
l'objet des groupes de travail qui doit
aujourd'hui
réfléchir à faire effectivement un
certain nombre de propositions pour
accompagner les difficultés de ces
élèves pour donner les moyens aux
enseignants pour leur permettre d'avoir
des leviers pédagogiques plus ajustés
plus agiles qui leur permettent
effectivement de mettre en situation de
réussite ses élèves et qui permettent
aussi leur permettre aussi de s'appuyer
sur des partenaires et je pense à des
dispositifs comme un jeune Inventor qui
peuvent aussi être des solutions de
soutien et accompagner les équipes
pédagogiques les enseignants à la
réussite de ces jeunes et un
accompagnement personnalisé qui leur
redonne confiance et qui leur donne du
sens au parcours de formation qui est le
leur et au projet professionnel qui sont
en train de se construire vous voyez
pour notre part de nos posons pas les
sujets et nous pensons que si
effectivement enseignants cherchent à
faire réussir leurs élèves nous devons
leur donner les moyens de réussir cet
exercice merci Monsieur chanterelle 6
secondes
je vais être très rapide on a un vrai
souci se débat est organisé parce que
vous passez par dessus la représentation
nationale à travers la voie
réglementaire et ça c'est un vrai
problème démocratique qui est posée par
votre gouvernement n'ayant pas peur du
débat posez-nous un texte on pourra
l'enrichir on pourra l'améliorer mais
arrêter en tout cas de de passer par
dessus la représentation nationale 6
secondes ne sont pas 18 secondes
la parole est maintenant monsieur
Jean-Henri pour le groupe Union
centriste
bien merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre mes chers collègues dans une
émission à grande écoute tout récemment
on racontait l'histoire de cette
entrepreneur façadier obligé de créer sa
propre école de formation pour pallier
les carences de l'État
cet exemple n'en est qu'un parmi tant
d'autres tant le désorient est grand
dans les différentes filières alors
madame la ministre ma question est
double quel bilan faites-vous de la
transformation de la voie
professionnelle menée par Jean-Michel
Blanquer en 2019 et ma deuxième question
à l'heure où l'on parle de facilité
l'accès de certains immigrés à des
métiers dit en tension pourquoi n'a-t-on
pas prévu les structures de formation
professionnelle Haddock nous sommes
persuadés que la conjoncture économique
oblige à la prise en compte d'une
valorisation des métiers manuels et
techniques et d'un plan de communication
rendant attractif les métiers en tension
je crois qu'il est de notre devoir de
répondre à l'inquiétude des entreprises
et d'offrir aux jeunes un projet porteur
de véritables espoir et de véritables
débouchés professionnels et surtout
disons-le madame la ministre pour ces
jeunes de gagner leur vie alors
comparaison n'est pas raison et sans
vouloir faire de généralité de non le
salaire d'un Facilier en début de
carrière environ 2000 euros mensuel net
alors il y a urgence à communiquer sur
ce qu'on gagne grâce au travail de la
main alors il y a urgence de retrouver
la valeur de la compétence qui viendrait
renforcer la valeur du travail
favorisant ainsi la justice sociale pour
construire une France heureuse je vous
remercie merci la parole est à madame la
ministre
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur au fond vous m'interrogez sur
la transformation de la voix
professionnelle telle que elle a été
portée sous le précédent mandat et qui a
effectivement fait l'objet d'un premier
bilan d'un bilan qui au fond est concret
positif elle avait effectivement pour
principe fondateur de recentrer le lycée
professionnel autour de l'élève et de la
personnalisation de son parcours je
crois que le comité national a été mis
en place en septembre 2019 pour
trimestriellement cette transformation
engagée de la voie professionnelle et
qui commence effectivement à rendre ses
conclusions pour ensuite associer
l'ensemble des acteurs à ce partage de
bilan la TVP a été déployée dans tous
les lycées professionnels et ce malgré
la crise sanitaire et je tiens en
remercier chaleureusement l'ensemble des
personnels éducatifs et enseignants car
je sais tout l'investissement qu'ils ont
mis dans cette transformation c'est
innovations pédagogiques elles ont
permis effectivement la cour
intervention qui a été installé avec des
résultats de qualité qui permettent de
renforcer le nombre d'heures à effectif
réduit et d'associer plus étroitement
les enseignements généraux des
enseignements professionnels de
spécialité mais je pense aussi au
chef-d'oeuvre qui a été proposé aux
élèves de lycée professionnel pour
construire un projet pluridisciplinaire
et qui notamment sur certains secteurs
plus particulièrement on fait l'objet de
d'émulation de nombreuses réalisations
d'élèves qui apportent aussi l'image
positive de la voix professionnelle que
nous devons pouvoir renforcer au fond je
crois que cette réforme elle a eu comme
bien fait principal de mieux construire
leur propre parcours sur mesure c'est un
des enjeux qu'on a déjà évoqué c'est
celui de donner du sens aux jeunes de
leur donner effectivement l'envie
l'investissement pour pouvoir
effectivement aller au bout de leur
formation cette réforme a aussi permis
de renforcer les campus des métiers des
qualifications et qui ont véritablement
sur les territoires créer des émulations
autour d'une meilleure organisation
entre les acteurs qui je crois a été le
fruit d'une amélioration des résultats
voilà parmi les questionnements qui
subsistent notamment je citerai
notamment celui de l'accompagnement
renforcé l'orientation parmi les
familles de métiers en seconde et c'est
là aussi un des sujets travaillés par
les groupes de travail merci
je pense que votre constat du site sur
ce qui a été proposé à l'époque par
Jean-Michel Blanquer permettra et
répondra j'espère un début de
questionnement et de dialogues comme le
souhaite mes collègues présents ce soir
dans l'hémicycle je pense que c'est
important vraiment que les jeunes
puissent valoriser l'envie de travailler
de travailler avec la main de pouvoir
faire des choses de gagner leur vie et
tout ceci naturellement dans le but de
ramener la France au travail et
d'envisager aussi le débat que nous
aurons dans quelques temps avec le
ministre Darmanin
merci la parole maintenant monsieur
Stéphane piennois pour le groupe les
républicains
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre je profite de l'ouverture
aujourd'hui de la semaine européenne
pour l'emploi des personnes handicapées
pour attirer votre attention sur la
situation des lycéens professionnels en
situation de handicap plus de 3/4 des
lycéens en situation de handicap sont
scolarisés dans la filière
professionnelle alors que les lycée pro
ne représentent que 30% des effectifs de
l'ensemble des lycées cette
disproportion alimente bien évidemment
l'idée d'une voix plutôt subie que
choisi pour ces lycéens deux impératifs
doivent se conjuguer celui de
l'importance de conforter les
fondamentaux académiques et celui de
mettre en place des dispositifs
renforcés pour l'insertion dans le
milieu professionnel sur ces deux points
les axes de réforme annoncés par le
président Emmanuel Macron interroge avec
une augmentation du temps prévu pour les
stages certains s'inquiètent d'une
diminution du socle commun
de connaissances pardon cela peut avoir
d'autant plus de conséquences négatives
pour les élèves en situation de handicap
qui nécessitent vous le savez bien bien
souvent un accompagnement individualisé
par ailleurs alors que l'obligation
légale d'emploi des travailleurs
handicapés est fixés à 6% dans les
administrations et les entreprises de
plus de 20 salariés la réalité est bien
en deçà aux alentours de 3,4%. les
raisons affichées par les employeurs
sont bien souvent une crainte de ne pas
pouvoir accueillir et encadrer
convenablement ces travailleurs sur ce
point l'entrée dans l'entreprise d'une
personne en situation de handicap par le
biais d'un stage est une réelle
opportunité d'insertion mais reste la
difficulté pour eux encore plus
importante que pour les autres lycéens
professionnels de trouver une structure
pour les accueillir aussi madame la
ministre pouvez-vous nous indiquer si la
situation particulière des lycéens en
situation de handicap sera prise en
compte au sein des fameux groupes de
travail que vous avez constitués et dans
un contexte ou de nombreux lycéens
éprouvent des difficultés pour trouver
un stage en lien direct avec le métier
auquel il se forme prévoyez-vous des
mesures spécifiques pour assurer au
lycée infragilisé par le handicap de
trouver des entreprises pour les
accueillir je vous remercie merci madame
la ministre
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur pied-noir vous poser là une
question essentielle qui est celle
effectivement de l'école plus inclusive
elle prend un sens tout particulièrement
prégnant effectivement au lycée
professionnel qui accueille dorénavant
31 000 élèves en situation de handicap
soit 5% des effectifs contre 3% il y a
encore 5 ans et effectivement pour les
accompagner dans la réussite de leur
scolarité un effort important et réalisé
notamment au travers de l'ouverture
d'unité localisée pour l'Inclusion
Scolaire on en dénombre plus de 500 en
lycée professionnel et 300 en lycée
polyvalent avec beaucoup de création
durant les toutes dernières années ces
Ulis elle sont 9 fois sur 10
spécialisées dans les troubles de des
fonctions cognitives elles sont
effectivement plus fréquemment constaté
effectivement chez les élèves en
situation de handicap dans la voie
professionnelle nous devons donc
faire mieux faire mieux pour accompagner
aussi le non diagnostic des lèvres
encore en lycée professionnel qui ne
sont pas encore diagnostiqués et notre
dispositif d'accompagnement présente des
limites sur lesquels je souhaite que
nous puissions travailler aussi pour un
diagnostic même tardif ces progrès
devront bien sûr aussi concerner la
scolarité mais aussi la préparation à
l'insertion professionnelle et vous avez
souhaité m'interroger sur le sujet à
chaque fois qu'on trouve une solution à
chaque fois que on permet effectivement
d'accéder à l'emploi à une personne en
situation de handicap je crois que c'est
toute la société qui gagne et les
groupes de travail doivent penser aussi
ce sujet l'idée c'est d'abord de donner
des leviers aux enseignants pour qu'ils
préparent ils accompagnent mieux les
élèves en situation de handicap et
adapter la pédagogie à ce public la
CNCPH sera auditionnée bientôt à la part
le groupe de travail et puis les
enseignants de lycée professionnel comme
l'ensemble des enseignants sont formés à
la pédagogie adaptée aux élèves en
situation de handicap et nous souhaitons
poursuivre et accentuer la formation
continue comme un levier pour les
enseignants de la voie professionnelle
pour mieux accompagner ses élèves j'ai
souhaité également que nous puissions
organiser le renforcement entre l'école
et l'entreprise pour qu'un meilleur
accueil des élèves en situation de
handicap soit effectués car là aussi
nous sommes convaincus que le
rapprochement et que l'entreprise pour
ses élèves permettra de mieux réussir
merci Madame la Ministre la parole
l'état Madame Corinne Ferret pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
République merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre comme mes collègues
l'ont déjà fait je vais vous interroger
ou intervenir sur le projet de réforme
de la voie professionnelle je ne
reviendrai pas sur ce qui apparaît comme
une remise en cause du caractère
national de l'accès aux formations
professionnelles pour les jeunes mais
aussi pour les diplômes professionnels
je reviendrai pas non plus sur votre
volonté d'hyper spécialisée les élèves
des lycées professionnels en lien avec
les besoins immédiats d'entreprises
locales je souhaite ici rappeler que les
élèves des lycées professionnels ont
comme tout autre lycéen au lycéennes
besoin d'acquérir des savoirs
fondamentaux acquisition déjà fragilisée
par la réforme bancaire ils doivent
pouvoir bénéficier d'heures
d'enseignement tant dans les disciplines
générales que professionnels notamment
pour améliorer leur réussite aux examens
déjà qui entre en CAP comme en bac pro à
14 ou 15 ans ont besoin d'être encadrés
par les professionnels de l'éducation
que sont leurs professeurs avec la
croissance plus 50% du temps dédié au
stage professionnel cette réforme
conduira inévitablement à la diminution
des ordres d'enseignement et aussi
pressions de postes qui vont avec que
vous le vouliez ou non que vous ne le
disiez pas ou non ou oui on va dire je
ne sais comment dire parce que c'est
assez flou cela est une réalité et que
penser de la formule du président de la
République disons vouloir s'appuyer je
cite sur des professeurs associés pour
aider à injecter des compétences dans
les lycées professionnels mais des
compétences il y en a déjà croyez moi
dans mon département le Calvados comme
ailleurs dans tous les lycées les
compétences sont là à terme tout porte à
croire qu'on s'achemine surtout vers une
remise en cause du statut du professeur
de lycée professionnel
aussi pouvez-vous nous expliquer en quoi
votre projet de réforme n'est pas
purement et simplement budgétaire
battant en brèche l'idée maîtresse qui
devrait pourtant toujours guider une
réforme de l'éducation nationale à
savoir la démocratisation d'éducation et
un égal accès au savoir quel que soit
son appartenance sociale merci Madame le
Ministre
vous savez je crois que effectivement
cette question du rapprochement et que
l'entreprise elle est même démontrée
scientifiquement s'il faut que je vous
renvoie à des études je peux vous
renvoyer à des études je pense
effectivement à Brooks
weiber qui effectivement ont fait des
études et qui montrent que leur
approchement avec l'entreprise est une
des conditions d'une meilleure insertion
quand en effet faire un stage est un
signal positivement perçu par
l'employeur qui permet aux élèves
d'acquérir de nouvelles compétences
opposées encore une fois la question des
savoirs fondamentaux à l'entreprise et à
mon sens dommage et dommageable pour les
élèves nous ne renonçons en rien aux
objectifs d'élévation du niveau général
des élèves professionnels et la réforme
ne sera pas faite en renonçant aux
enseignements fondamentaux comme je l'ai
dit à plusieurs reprises notre objectif
au travers de cette réforme il est
d'investir davantage d'investir
davantage dans les lycées professionnels
parce que nous sommes convaincus que
c'est un des leviers de réussite de
notre jeunesse par lequel je le rappelle
entière des lycéens le gouvernement est
donc prêt à un investissement massif et
prêt à accompagner ces élèves pour la
réussite dans leur diplôme mais aussi
dans la construction de leur avenir au
fond vous traitez de flou une
concertation qui est faite avec
l'ensemble des acteurs ce que je
regrette profondément au fond vous n'y
est notre capacité à faire participer
l'ensemble des acteurs du monde éducatif
de la formation de l'emploi pour
co-construire une réforme qui doit être
systémique une réforme qui doit être
progressive uniforme une réforme qui
doit être ambitieuse et au service des
élèves cette réforme elle sera celle de
la valorisation du lycée professionnel
de ses élèves de ses professeurs nous y
parviendrons car nous en sommes
convaincus faire de l'apprentissage a
été une voix reconnue faire demain du
lycée professionnel une voix aussi
reconnue est un défi que nous pouvons
atteindre nous avons la même ambition et
nous souhaitons effectivement avec
détermination accompagner cette ambition
pour la réussite des lycées
professionnels merci la parole est à
madame Béatrice Gosselin pour le groupe
les républicains monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre
avant la réforme de l'apprentissage la
corde la carte de formation des CFA sur
les territoires étaient de la compétence
des régions et une dotation a été
allouée à chaque CFA selon leur
engagement à maintenir une offre de
formation au plus près des besoins
afin de dynamiser et éviter les
disparités d'offres de formation d'un
territoire à l'autre France compétences
est devenue sous la réforme avenir
professionnel de 2018 l'unique instance
nationale de l'apprentissage qui assure
le financement et la régulation de la
formation professionnelle et ouvre le
marché des formations aux filières et un
très grand nombre d'opérateurs
le développement de l'apprentissage qui
a presque doublé en quatre ans a été
rendu possible par la libéralisation du
système et par la mise en place de
fortes incitations financières pour les
entreprises qui accueillent un apprenti
prime exceptionnel de 5000 à 8000 euros
selon l'âge exonération des charges fin
2022 en Normandie ont dénombré 120
centres de formation contre 59 en 2018
cependant cette évolution qui permet de
répondre en partie aux besoins des
entreprises a profondément transformer
l'équilibre des formations sur notre
territoire posant alors la question de
la concurrence entre établissement de
formation professionnelle par exemple
dans la Manche à côté du d'un lycée
professionnel spécialisé sur les métiers
de la métallurgie s'ouvrent un CFA axé
sur la même formation
cette concurrence s'exerce de manière
plus forte dans les zones rurales et
fragilisent le maillage territorial de
la formation
contrairement à l'apprentissage qui
longtemps dévalorisé redevient une
formation initiale reconnue les lycées
professionnels n'ont pas réussi à
convaincre de l'excellence de leur
enseignement et peine à recruter ces
établissements déjà perçus présents sur
nos territoires devraient pourtant être
complémentaires avec d'autres centres de
formation et non en concurrence directe
alors madame la ministre quelle mesure
comptez-vous prendre pour en finir avec
la concurrence entre CFA et lycée
professionnel et pour qu'enfin la
filière de l'enseignement professionnel
redevienne attractive je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice je crois vraiment avoir à
plusieurs reprises indiquées la position
extrêmement claire qui est la mienne qui
est celle du gouvernement
l'apprentissage et la formation initiale
en voie professionnelle ne sont pas
concurrentes mais bien complémentaires
et donc je le redis si vous souhaitez
que je puisse le redire ces voix elles
ne conserve pas les mêmes profils de
jeunes qui sont à des étapes de vie
différentes et qui souvent sont même pas
sur les mêmes niveaux de diplôme le
gouvernement a cherché enfin cherchent à
construire avec tous les acteurs
concernés une réforme de l'enseignement
professionnel qui vise à sécuriser les
parcours des jeunes en leur permettant
des parcours possiblement mixtes entre
formation et apprentissage il y en a
déjà 60000 en lycée professionnel avec
une forte augmentation en deux ans mais
ce n'est pas la seule voie possible de
réussite en lycée professionnel ce que
nous cherchons c'est la valorisation
pour le Lycée professionnel avec la même
ambition avec le même engagement que
celui que nous avons eu par là pour la
voie de l'apprentissage nous de nombreux
leviers qui sont posés dans ces groupes
de travail celui de la formation des
professeurs les formations d'avenir en
phase avec des évolutions économiques le
renforcement des enseignements au lycée
professionnel l'intensification de
l'accompagnement tous ces leviers je
crois ne souffre d'aucune concurrence
entre apprentissage et lycée
professionnel d'ailleurs la durée n'est
absolument pas la même la durée en
apprentissage est de 88 semaines contre
33 semaines en lycée professionnel même
avec l'augmentation de période de
formation en milieu professionnel
l'exercice des stages se fait dans des
lieux dans des entreprises différentes
pour les périodes de formation en milieu
professionnel au fond vous voyez je
crois qu'on est véritablement sur deux
dispositifs qui doivent pouvoir être
deux voix pour les jeunes dans lesquels
possiblement il y ait des passerelles si
le jeûne le souhaite au fond moi ce qui
m'importe c'est l'insertion
professionnelle des jeunes la
progression qualitative des périodes de
formation en milieu professionnel sur
lesquels les organisations syndicales
éducation m'ont interpellé car de
nombreux échanges en la matière doivent
pouvoir être fait pour améliorer la
qualité de ces périodes de formation qui
doivent être véritablement au service de
l'éducation de nos jeunes merci la
parole est maintenant Madame Anne
vantalon pour le groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues l'annonce
de la réforme du lycée professionnel qui
n'a pas été précédé d'aucun travail de
concertation a suscité l'inquiétude des
élèves de leur famille et du corps
enseignant malgré un récent
infléchissement de son discours les
intentions du Gouvernement demeure floue
et source de préoccupations je
souhaiterais ainsi revenir sur la
question de l'allongement de 50% des
périodes de formation en milieu
professionnel à moins de surcharger les
semaines cette augmentation du temps
passé un stage impliquera donc une
diminution des heures d'enseignement
général et professionnels français
mathématiques mais aussi gestion ou
économie autant de matières qui doivent
être dispensés pour préparer ce qui le
souhaitent à un cursus dans
l'enseignement supérieur mais aussi
parce que le lycée forme des adolescents
destinés à devenir des citoyens capables
de comprendre et de s'épanouir dans le
monde où ils évoluent forgez leur esprit
à la logique leur transmettre la
connaissance de leur histoire et d'une
culture générale sans omettre
l'indispensable apprentissage du
français et des langues vivantes
constituent des préalables impératifs à
la cohésion de notre société l'équation
est donc la suivante comment augmenter
les périodes de formation sans toucher
au volume horaire des enseignements
généraux et professionnels si une
certaine autonomie dans la vie de ces
établissements peut leur être bénéfiques
l'organisation locale des heures
d'enseignement ne risque-t-elle pas de
remettre en cause le caractère national
du diplôme la réforme fait actuellement
l'objet d'une concertation lancée le 21
octobre je ne veux donc pas préjugé les
conclusions que vous en tirerez mais je
tiens à mon tour vous interpeller et
entendre votre avis sur ce sujet
préoccupant les conséquences de la
diminution du temps scolaire sur
l'avenir de nos lycéens je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice Ventalon écoutez permettez-moi
quand même de replacer la place du
dialogue social dans le travail
préparatoire je les ai reçus dès ma
nominations en juillet les organisations
syndicales éducation ont tout été
rencontrées je me suis attachée dès les
premiers jours de ma nomination je me
suis également attachée tout le mois de
septembre avec au fond une procédure
d'accord de méthode que nous avons
conclu au mois de juillet j'ai rencontré
également les organisations syndicales
interprofessionnelles dans ce même
objectif ainsi que les organisations
patronales j'ai également participé à un
certain nombre de concertations locales
dans le cadre du CNR et c'est important
pour moi de continuer à le faire et je
continuerai à le faire les groupes de
travail sont également un lieu de
dialogue et de co-construction de
solutions et dans lequel sont les
organisations syndicales éducation
l'organisation syndicale
interprofessionnelle organisation
patronale région enseignants
parents d'élèves élèves inspecteur
recteur expert vous voyez bien nous
avons cherché à associer un maximum
d'acteurs et c'est bien dans cette
démarche de dialogue social que nous
sommes vous ne pouvez pas non plus nous
jeter le propre du flou alors que nous
sommes justement en train de
co-construire une réforme du lycée
professionnel qui a des enjeux majeurs
absolument structurels vous comprenez
que effectivement les enseignements
fondamentaux sont préservés le président
de la République à Tabarly le 13
septembre dernier la réaffirmé je l'ai
moi-même réaffirmé au fond un certain
nombre de modalités peuvent être pensés
c'est tout l'objet des groupes de
travail autour de temps supplémentaires
qui peuvent être donnés
en amont du diplôme poste diplôme de
réorganisation des temps de stage des
réflexions qui sont au fond sur la table
et qui doivent permettre aux acteurs qui
sont dans ces dans ces champs de pouvoir
réfléchir autour d'une intelligence
collective à laquelle je crois
profondément la qualité de proposition
qui serait une réponse à l'ensemble des
sujets sur lesquels vous m'interpellez
cette réforme elle n'a pas pour objectif
de faire des économies elle elle est
véritablement un investissement comme
cela n'a jamais été encore fait pour
faire réussir tous les élèves nous le
devons au tiers de lycéen qui passe par
la voie professionnelle merci la parole
maintenant madame Dominique Estrosi ça
sonne pour le groupe les républiques
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre ma question porte sur
l'articulation de la réforme de
l'enseignement professionnel qui
inquiète un secteur vous en conviendrez
madame la ministre peu enclin à la
protestation et qui s'est pourtant
fortement mobilisé le 18 octobre dernier
l'augmentation du nombre de semaines de
stage dont le temps en entreprise sera
désormais rémunéré soulève la question
du pilotage de la réforme et de son
financement puisque les ministères de
l'Éducation nationale et du travail sont
appelés à collaborer et cela me semble
ça va être compliqué la rémunération des
élèves sera-t-elle assurée par les
entreprises et une partie sera-t-elle
prise en charge par l'État dans ce cas
quel ministère sera concerné la question
du choc de l'offre pour les stages est
aussi une inquiétude s'il a été démontré
qu'il existe une synergie entre les
lycées professionnels et les entreprises
locales dans moyenne la situation est
beaucoup plus inquiétante à l'échelle
des grandes agglomérations à cela
s'ajoute l'éventuelle concurrence avec
l'apprentissage a fortiori dans un tissu
d'entreprise qui reste en nombre limité
entendez-vous établir une cartographie
des bassins d'emploi et y associer
directement les élus lors de la
présentation de la réforme en septembre
le président de la République a expliqué
que cette réforme en vigueur entrera en
vigueur de manière très progressive mais
l'inquiétude ne faiblit pas une nouvelle
journée de mobilisation nationale et
d'ailleurs prévue cette semaine le 17
novembre faute de feuilles de route pour
les enseignants pouvez-vous enfin leur
apporter des réponses précises merci
madame la ministre
merci monsieur le Président Madame les
sénatrices je vais essayer de répondre
au maximum à toutes les questions que
vous avez pu poser en deux minutes
écoutez je voudrais redire à quel point
cet enjeu de relation école entreprise
elle dépasse la question d'un territoire
ou de l'autre d'une zone rurale ou d'une
autre c'est-à-dire tout à l'heure quand
je citer le taux de 80 % de réussisse de
réussite d'insertion professionnelle sur
un des diplômes au fond il se traduit
aussi bien dans la ruralité que dans les
oignons urbaines donc véritablement le
sujet dépasse cela on a des énormes
disparités de réussite d'insertion
professionnelle et je salue bien sûr
l'immense travail qui est fait par les
équipes pédagogiques en la matière il
s'agit véritablement maintenant d'aller
plus loin pour permettre une réforme
profondément structurelle tournée vers
les élèves vers leur insertion
professionnelle qui doit véritablement
les accompagner partout sur le
territoire notamment sur l'exemple de ce
qui peut être fait sur les campus des
métiers des qualifications mais pas
seulement je voudrais redire à quel
point la gratification sera opérée par
l'État et j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de de
redire mais je le redis la gratification
des périodes de formation milieu
professionnel seront réalisés par l'État
nous souhaitons véritablement renforcer
cette synergie état entreprise
évidemment avec les acteurs locaux
notamment au travers des régions qui ont
cette compétence pour travailler avec le
rectorat sur la carte des formations
j'ai eu l'occasion de rencontrer
l'ensemble des régions soit par
entretien individuel avec les présidents
de région soit alors de la commission
formation à la Réunion enfin lors d'une
réunion de commission formation à la
région région de France il s'agit
véritablement pour moi de travailler
main dans la main avec eux d'outillés
aussi cette j'ai envie de cette ambition
pour les cartes de formation d'être à
l'écoute des régions et de leurs acteurs
économiques pour mieux accompagner cette
réalité de la transformation des cartes
de formation c'est essentiel de pouvoir
effectivement le conduire de le conduire
avec eux avec elle parce que évidemment
tous ces enjeux investissement qu'il y a
derrière doivent pouvoir se penser
évidemment en coopération
je n'aurais pas le temps de répondre à
toutes vos questions vous dire que si
nous sommes suscite sur les constats
nous sommes évidemment dans une démarche
d'investissement et de coopération avec
les acteurs merci Madame Estrosi ça
sonne 15 secondes
[Musique]
il y a un certain nombre de verrous
budgétaires réglementaires mais
également des verrous dans l'orientation
qui doivent encore sauter qui nous
empêchent d'avancer dans cette réforme
du lycée professionnel merci la parole
est à Monsieur Edouard Courtial pour le
groupe les républicain
merci président madame la ministre si
comparaison n'est pas raison il est
toujours intéressant surtout dans un
monde concurrentiel et globalisé comme
le nôtre d'apprendre de ses voisins et
partenaires une déformation personnelle
sans doute pour le membre de la
commission des affaires étrangères que
je suis
dévalorisé le plébisciter par les
parents dans l'Hexagone l'enseignement
professionnel est encore fortement
associé à la faiblesse des résultats
scolaires et au poids des origines
sociales ainsi qu'à une vision exclusive
et négative de la pratique des métiers
manuels c'était pas du tout le cas en
Allemagne ou en Suisse ou une longue
tradition et favorable à la voix
professionnalisante d'ailleurs dans
presque tous les pays de l'OCDE un
diplôme donné les voies professionnelles
bénéficient d'une meilleure insertion
que les voies Générales ainsi madame la
ministre comment comptez-vous améliorer
son image alors qu'il s'agit d'une voie
vers l'emploi indispensable à de
nombreux jeunes
en outre la France figure parmi les pays
les moins avancés au regard de la
modularisation de ces diplômes car elle
concerne seulement une petite partie des
titres alors qu'en Écosse ou en
Angleterre les parcours de formation
peuvent se constituer à la carte par
ailleurs la France est un pays trop
normé avec la limite de l'âge ou des
conditions de travail comme pour les
boulangeries ou les élèves ne peuvent
travailler sur des horaires forcément
matinaux exemple de l'âge d'accès aux
formations en France en troisième
nettement plutôt en Allemagne et en
Autriche ainsi madame la ministre
comment donner davantage de souplesse
pour maximiser les chances de réussite
je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur courscial au fond vous
m'interrogez déjà sur la question de
l'image du lycée professionnel dans
notre pays qui est effectivement
l'affaire de tous politique publique
entreprise médias parents professeurs
acteurs de l'école et bien entendu les
jeunes eux-mêmes et leur famille c'est
évidemment un enjeu très fort mais il
passera je crois déjà par le caractère
insérant des formations plus une
formation permettra l'accès à l'emploi
et la réussite de parcours plus elle
sera attractive et on peut le voir à
quel point nous avons de beaux parcours
à Bac moins 3 aussi bien que au niveau
ingénieur et c'est important de
valoriser ces réussites je pense par
exemple la très belle compétition des
worskiss qui effectivement
promeeux des rôles modèles qui montrent
l'excellence des filières et des
parcours et c'est tout l'objectif de ce
type de compétition de l'olympiade des
métiers qui ont pour mission la
promotion des métiers et la valorisation
des voies professionnelles nous
souhaitons bien sûr aussi renforcer les
savoirs fondamentaux qui sont des
savoirs utiles à tous citoyen éclairés
et c'est essentiel d'accompagner cette
dimension là nous souhaitons aussi que
le lycée professionnel se place au
centre de de des enjeux compétences pour
les filières dont la nation a besoin
demain c'était essentiel que les
professionnels puissent penser le monde
économique de demain préparer leurs
élèves à ces enjeux préparer leurs
élèves à bien sûr s'insérer dans
l'emploi et être capable de s'ajuster
aux mutations économiques au fond ce que
je veux vous dire là monsieur le
sénateur c'est que bien sûr nous sommes
conscients du besoin d'assouplissement
et de la réglementation pour l'accueil
de jeunes dans certaines situations mais
elles doivent se faire aucun par cas
parce que si l'enjeu d'assouplir est
évident il est aussi évidemment une
priorité pour nous de préserver la
sécurité de nos jeunes qui n'est
évidemment pas négociable et que le fait
que la qualité des stages doit être
aussi en adéquation avec l'enjeu du
rapprochement de l'É à l'entreprise
l'enjeu qui est pour nous c'est
effectivement de permettre à l'élève
d'avoir plus de code de d'avoir plus de
liens d'avoir plus de contacts et c'est
là je crois une collaboration que nous
devons renforcer entre les professeurs
des tuteurs d'entreprise co-construire
finalement ce parcours de compétences
des jeunes j'en vous remercie merci pour
conclure le débat la parole est à
Monsieur Stéphane piénoir pour le groupe
les républicains pour 5 minutes
tout ça
c'est le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues avec la
mastification de l'accès au baccalauréat
dans les années 80 il est apparu
nécessaire d'offrir une pluralité
d'orientation correspondant dans la
mesure du possible à la diversité des
profils des chères têtes blondes de
notre pays l'objectif du bac
professionnel était de proposer une
formation un peu moins théorique dans le
champ de l'enseignement général et de la
compléter par un enseignement
professionnel de nature à encourager des
vocations dans les métiers dit manuel
chacun sait qu'en réalité il s'agit
souvent d'une orientation par défaut
c'est-à-dire lorsqu'on estime que
l'accès au baccalauréat général est
impossible la filière est
considérablement des considéré par les
familles et largement méconnue par les
enseignants qui sont pourtant eux-mêmes
chargés de cette orientation
l'ambition était belle mais 40 ans plus
tard le constat le constat est amer pour
Daniel Bloch le père du bac pro en 1985
que je cite ici baisse significative du
niveau des élèves entrant dans
l'enseignement professionnel perte de
valeur marchande du baccalauréat
professionnel ou encore très modeste
tout d'emplois indiscutablement les
difficultés de la filière
professionnelle nécessite une réflexion
de fond pour imaginer une refonte de
cette voie importante de notre système
éducatif mais les débats d'aujourd'hui
soulignent les divergences presque
autant sur la méthode adoptée par le
gouvernement que sur la finalité espérée
pour cette filière professionnelle new
look
il y a d'abord la vision jupiterienne
celle qui consiste à dire à l'avance
précisément ce qu'il convient de faire
tout en convoquant une énième forme de
concertation chargée bien sûr de valider
in extenso ces propositions qui peut
raisonnablement s'étonner des réactions
négatives à ce mode de fonctionnement
politique cette sorte de management par
l'imposition d'une vérité divine il y a
ensuite la vision arithmétique qui
consiste à traduire le nombre d'heures
d'enseignements générales supprimés par
son équivalent en nombre de postes de
fonctionnaires 7000 à 8000 selon Daniel
block chiffre lui-même traduit en
économie budgétaire réalisée sur une
année ou un quinquennat je ne veux pas
croire qu'une telle démarche puisse
guider à elle seule une réforme de notre
système éducatif
il y a la vision syndicale celle qui
considère que tout projet de réforme
contient des facto une Athènes une
atteinte au statut de la corporation et
qu'il convient donc de s'y opposer
fermement parfois même avant d'être
sollicité quelques syndicats on est en
moins accepté de participer aux
discussions et aux premiers ateliers de
travail tout en soutenant les
mobilisations du 18 octobre dernier et
du 17 novembre prochain le dialogue
social n'est pas le point fort de notre
pays mais je forme le vœu d'une occasion
de repartir sur de bonnes bases pour
engager de vraies discussions même si
infinie évidemment tout le monde ne
pourra pas tomber totalement d'accord
il y a ensuite la vision comptable celle
qui s'inquiète légitimement de la
rémunération des jeunes en entreprise si
la durée des stages est
significativement augmentée dans les
médias vous avez en partie répondu à
cette question durant notre débat en
assurant que l'étage auront pleinement
son rôle à ce niveau et nous en prenons
acte
il y a également la vision économique
qui consiste à identifier chaque élève
de la filière professionnelle comme un
potentiel futur candidat à l'embauche
dans le secteur correspondant à sa
formation les entreprises n'ont certes
pas à définir elle-même les attendus de
chaque cursus mais nous nous serions pas
responsables si nous fermions les yeux
sur le financement massif de certaines
impasses notamment dans le secteur
tertiaire
identifié les besoins ne signifie pas
une traduction strictosensue sur la
carte scolaire mais constitue un
paramètre important
il y a enfin la vision territoriale
celle des régions qui apparaissent comme
me semble-t-il le meilleur soutien de la
voie professionnelle dont elle finance
largement les équipements des plateaux
techniques et également celle des lycées
elles aussi réclament une consultation
sincère et offre leur service pour
construire une carte des formations dans
le but de donner à chaque jeune une
possibilité de proximité dans son
insertion professionnelle certaines
tensions sur le marché du travail
s'annonce durable avec de grandes
disparités territoriales il convient d'y
répondre avec pragmatisme madame la
ministre cette liste n'est probablement
pas exhaustive mais montre bien que la
profondeur du sujet et la multiplicité
des acteurs nécessite une autre méthode
de concertation tous les chantiers liés
à l'éducation nationale sont facilement
inflammables et je m'étonne que votre
gouvernement ne prenne pas plus de temps
pour faire émerger des diagnostics
partagés avant d'engager la cavalerie
lourde d'une négociation au forceps par
exemple un bilan de la réforme
précédente est indispensable avant de
mettre sur la table toute la piste d'une
réforme ambitieuse avec comme seule
stratégie la réussite de tous nos jeunes
sur lesquels reposent le développement
et la prospérité de notre pays enfin
j'aimerais vous entendre dans la même
liste sur la future consultation le
Parlement pour faire aboutir cette
nouvelle réforme dans le respect strict
de nos institutions je vous remercie
merci chers collègues
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
je vais suspendre la séance elle sera
reprise à 21h30 pour le débat sur quel
bilan pour parcoursup la séance
est suspendue